apple is a company
that has
doesn't have the most resources of
everybody in the world
and
the way we've succeeded is by choosing
what horses to ride really carefully
technically we try to look for these
technical vectors that that have a
future
and that are headed up and you know
technology
different pieces of technology
kind of go in cycles they have their
their springs and summers and autumns
and then they
you know go to the graveyard of
technology
and
so we try to pick things that are in
their springs
and if you choose wisely
you can save yourself an enormous amount
of work versus trying to do everything
and you can really put energy into
making those new
emerging technologies uh be great on
your platform rather than just okay
because you're spreading yourself too
thin so we have a history of doing that
as an example uh we went from the five
inch floppy disk to the three and a half
inch floppy disk with the mac before
before other people right we were the
first to do that we made the three and a
half inch floppy this popular um sony
invented it and we we put it in in the
first products
um
and there were some good reasons we did
that uh we got rid of the floppy disk
altogether in
1998 with the first imac
we also got rid of these things called
serial and parallel ports and we were
the first to to adopt usb
even though intel had invented it you
first saw it in in mass on imax and so
we have gotten rid of things we were one
of the first to get rid of optical
drives with the macbook air
and uh and i think things are moving in
that direction as well and sometimes
when we get rid of things like the
floppy disk drive on the original imac
people call us crazy
um or at least premature maybe no they
call us crazy
and uh
uh
but
sometimes you just have to pick the
things that look like they're going to
be
the right horses to ride going forward
and what if people say
you know the ipad is uh
crippled in this respect well you know
what i'd say two things number one
things are packages
of of emphasis
some things are emphasized in a product
some things are not done as well in a
product some things are chosen not to be
done at all in a product and so
different people make different choices
and uh if the market tells us we're
making the wrong choices we listen to
the market we're just we're just people
running this company
we're trying to make great products for
people and so we have at least the
courage of our convictions to say
we don't think this is part of what
makes a great product we're going to
leave it out some people are going to
not like that they're going to call us
names it's not going to be in certain
companies vested interests that we do
that but we're going to take the heat
because we want to make the best product
in the world for customers we're going
to instead focus our energy on these
technologies which we think are in their
ascendancy and we think are going to be
the right technologies for customers and
you know what they're paying us to make
those choices
that's what a lot of customers pay us to
do is to try to make the best products
we can and if we succeed
they'll buy them
and if we don't
they
won't
and it'll all work itself out
if you want to get some steve jobs
motivation check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there a lot of people come to me they
say well i want to be an entrepreneur
and i go that's great what's your idea
and they go well i don't have one yet
and i say well i think you should go get
a job as a busboy or something until you
find something you're really passionate
about because